there's a democrat candidate running for
senate right now
who is
smoking a fat blunt in his campaign ad
and running on the platform of letting
other people puff on the devil's lettuce
every 37 seconds someone is arrested for
possession of marijuana since 2010 state
and local police have arrested an
estimated 7.3 million americans for
violating marijuana laws over half of
all drug arrests black people are four
times more likely to be arrested for
marijuana laws than white people states
waste 3.7 billion dollars in forcing
marijuana laws every year most of the
people police are arresting aren't
dealers but rather people with small
amounts of pot just like me i'm gary
chambers and i'm running for the u.s
senate and i approve this message
i
so hope
that that guy
got arrested
i assume he didn't but i just i have
this dream that that guy is sitting
there
spreading complete lies about
drugs and the criminal justice system
just complete made up nonsense he's
sitting there smoking his blunt and he's
filming and he's saying yeah you gotta
vote for me because the most important
issue in america the reason i'm running
for senate is so that people can just
smoke up that peruvian parsley every day
that'll make america great
and then they finish they say cut okay
we we're good we're good senate
candidate guy and then you just you're
like
and then the guy goes into the clink
this guy
is not telling the truth about drug laws
in america we are told by the pothead
contention now it's not even just a
pothead contingent that i i have any
problems with and it's not even
marijuana that i specifically have a
problem with
it's the it's the people
who
insist on the legalization of marijuana
as a cure is something that'll make
america so great and it'll it'll improve
society it's those people the obsessive
pro-legalization people they are the
reason
that i want to ban
every joint from america because they
are so annoying and dumb and wrong
that i don't want to hear them anymore
and that's one of the reasons i want to
do it
what this man is saying is not true
we're told that
the prisons are just full of poor men
usually black men by the way who were
arrested for simple possession they had
a joint they were just smoking a little
bit now they're going to jail for years
they're being probably 90 of the prison
population it's just these poor men
who were just trying to
just trying to puff on a little little
sin spinach and and they got arrested
that's not true
according to the hudson institute which
did a great review of this
just 3.6
of state prison inmates are in
jail for possession offenses of any kind
we're not we're not talking about
marijuana here we're talking about
heroin we're talking about fentanyl
we're talking about really bad stuff
that kills a lot of people
for possession of any kind it's just 3.6
percent
when you when you go up to the federal
prisons
the number's even lower it's 0.9
so why this confusion
well
it's actually not even just the 3.6 and
the 0.9 percent the numbers are actually
even lower because drug traffickers
usually plea down their their cases so
someone who's in prison for possession
very often is in prison for drug
trafficking and they just plead it down
and so then you you see them there for
simple possession in 2014 which is the
most recent year for which the hudson
institute has compiled its data the
number of inmates sentenced to federal
prison for marijuana possession
take a guess
if that pothead senate candidate is to
be believed you'd think what
50 000 people
10 000 people
certainly at least you'd say seven or
eight thousand people right
because the prisons are just filled with
this probably you'd think even even more
no the number
was 75
people not 75 000
not 7 500 75 people in 2014 were
sentenced to federal prison for
marijuana possession 97 percent of
federal inmates who are in for drugs are
in for drug trafficking
add to that that last year 100 000
americans died from drug overdoses
leading cause of death for young
americans
that was up 30 percent over the previous
year and these idiots think that the the
way to deal with that are our fellow
americans poisoning themselves to death
the way to deal with that
historic surge in drug overdoses is to
legalize drugs because of a problem that
doesn't exist namely the problem of mass
incarceration for simple possession
which is just a fantasy lock that away
with the tooth fairy and the easter
bunny
i don't know i don't know how that
senate candidate could have come up with
such stupid fantastical
ideas that are so divorced from reality
oh yeah i know because he's super high
that's probably that's probably why he
came up with it
good grief
if the if the smoke clouds would clear
away not not from the air in front of
him but from his brain he could look at
the real numbers and realize
that that what he's selling is a really
bad idea and it's unfortunate because so
many conservatives who are in under the
sway of
the libertines on the right the you know
maybe the libertarians even who say well
it's not the government's right to stop
you from doing drugs
they think this is fine too
if you believe
that giving that dude his way that
pothead senate candidate who thinks that
puffing a drug is the most important
issue in in american politics if you
think that doing what he wants is going
to make america better
i got a bridge in brooklyn to sell you
hey you
thanks for thanks for being here i'm
glad to see you i always like seeing you
when you come around these parts
unfortunately sometimes our our pals
here in the big tech world don't want to
give you notifications
about these new videos so to maximize
your chance of getting the notifications
ring that bell subscribe also if you
want to get the unvarnished uncensored
too hot for big tech
version of the show head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts type in the michael knowles
show subscribe for free
and leave a five-star review we'll see
you them
[Music]
[Music]